shireen rosen's still on the roster we
don't know how much longer that's going
to be we talked about this a little bit
earlier the prospect that the cardinals
would take kyle murray with the first
overall pick in the draft and would keep
josh rosen either way it's clear based
on his comments to sitv he is in the
dark and and my big takeaway from that
is no matter what they do going forward
if they don't take kylie murray it
undermines josh rosen to send the
message to the entire organization and
everyone else that that this guy really
isn't our guy
yeah they're gonna have to bring him
back into the fold if they end up
keeping him because i i do think they've
created something there that that
shouldn't be there it sounds like they
have not communicated very well what
their plans are and in some ways i
understand that and he understands as a
business i go back to the draft mike
when when he said that nine teams made a
mistake passing on me it was really
eight because the browns had two picks
in there but he said sort of the same
things yesterday too like if they trade
me i'm going to go out and prove them
wrong type deal so he's going to be
motivated no matter where he ends up to
prove that he's the quarterback that the
cardinals obviously thought he was last
year when they used the 10th pick on him
but the thing is you never make it go
away that period of time where he's in
the dark and he's supposed to be the guy
he's supposed to be the leader of the
team he doesn't know whether or not he's
going to be there and all those other
guys in the locker room are kind of
looking at him like boy they what do
they really think of you do they really
believe in you or is it just a matter of
time before they trade for somebody sign
somebody draft somebody like dude do we
really get behind you the way that we
should because the organization clearly
isn't behind you the way that it should
behind be behind a franchise quarterback
and you know one of the points i made
earlier on the radio side of the show
if this were happening in a place where
there is a clear-cut franchise
quarterback like green bay
just think about if aaron rodgers
was having to deal with this uncertainty
of whether or not he's going to be
supplanted by the first overall pick in
the draft at his position
people would be losing their minds and
it really would be a big deal because of
the name involved well i think it's
still a big deal to the extent that josh
rosen is supposed to be the guy that the
cardinals are rallying behind and the
mere fact that he's in this posture
tells me that kyle murray is going to be
the pick
yeah i agree with you completely i think
they've just showed their hand by what
they've told to josh rosen and his
quotes that come out
i want to see if he's going to talk to
the media before they the draft day on
thursday and i don't think they're going
to let him talk or he doesn't want to
talk or whatever the case may be but i
would love to get him in front of the
local media and see what else he has to
say because i'm sure the questions uh
might be a little bit harder than just
one person from si asking him
but it it i don't know what what their
future is but i think their future now
has to be probably without josh rosen
whether they keep him or not i don't
know that you can repair that as you
said just in the locker room they're
going to be looking at him going yeah
they didn't believe in you if kyler
murray's sitting over there he's the
quarterback of the future what are you
i think he's got to go somewhere else
but i don't know if they're going to
trade him somewhere else for less than a
first round draft pick and is somebody
willing to give that first round draft
pick for josh rosen is he better what
than what you can find in the draft when
you draft
and let's think about what he said to
sitv he said if they keep me i need to
prove them right if they get rid of me i
need to prove them wrong the middle
ground is they keep you as the backup to
kyler murray and and i think that the
most telling comments from josh rosen
would come after murray is picked and
before he is traded what's he going to
say then they can't hide this guy
forever unless they're going to trade
him right after they pick tyler murray
there is going to be that awkward moment
where josh rosen is talking about his
situation where he is number two behind
kyler murray and maybe he's going to say
hey why don't you just trade me and get
what you can for me i don't want to be
here if i'm on the bench
well he's never kept his mouth closed
either mike he is going to say something
because he does talk and he's very
quotable uh and and he's not
the right things that's not what josh
rosen does so i you know it's going to
be really fun if they do keep him and
and kyle murray's there too
to see what he says
i'm surprised that he's been as guarded
in his comments as he has because we
would expect him to maybe be a little
more candid about whatever frustration
he's feeling and you made a great point
last segment about cliff kingsbury and
his comments from the league meetings
where he gushed about murray more than
rosen it was it was easy for kingsbury
to say oh all that stuff i said during
the season about murray when we were
getting ready to play them that's just
talking up an opponent he didn't have
that excuse this time around it was
glaring given what he said and i just
think every little piece of the puzzle
points toward kyla murray being the
first overall pick no matter how much
they want to try to conceal it i think
that's where we're going
how much fun is it going to be though if
they don't take kyler murray
though that will def that will
definitely shake things up that will
definitely make next thursday night's
show on abc espn and nfl network even
more fascinating to see where they go
from there and how they try to rebuild
that that overall image and stature of
josh rosen in the locker room
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports